I love you guys so much and I was coming
very soon and everything's good I'm
super super happy that was Selena Gomez
earlier this year teasing in her new
album I'm just nervous about it
obviously because I feel like the next
few choices that I'm gonna meet are very
crucial so I'm trying to be really
really diligent and just patient and now
we know the album is done and how's this
for good news source tells Edie she
plans to release it sometime this year
and it's going to be a super personal
quote Selena has gone through a lot over
the years and is ready to share it with
the world
Julia Michaels one of Selena's BFFs and
often collaborator shared a similar
sentiment last fall revealing Selena's
writing it's herself she keeps TV new
music we're dying to know if you guys
are working together again no no I'm not
she's amazing I think she wants to do
her own things and have her own words
and her only expressions and and I think
that's amazing I want her to flourish
yeah she deserves it everything selena
just celebrated her 27th birthday in
italy and our source says she's in a
really good place so i love you all it's
been a while since we've heard solo
music from selena her last hits were
collapse i can't get enough
and talkie-talkie which car DB was also
a part of I'm obsessed with her she's so
sweet and she's very honest and I
respect them what does that friendship
mean to you it's great because I felt
like when we got to work on the video we
were able to be there for a while and
there was no pressure everything was
super laid back I just think she's
hilarious and she brings a fiery and
energy into anything all we know is we
can't wait I'm very lucky I'm grateful
so
[Music]